have you heard of dry january it's a
time of sobriety after months of holiday
indulging some do it for weight loss
others to curb any bad habits they may
have come up with bianca holman joining
us live now bianca you know i understand
the critics of dry january they
say that it hurts local bars
yeah if you think about it our
restaurant industry has suffered because
of kovitz so if there's another added
layer of people not going out to drink
they say we'll think about the
businesses but overall health experts
say well think about the bigger picture
it's just for a moment and there are
great health benefits and can benefit a
lot of people so
no alcohol no hard liquor no wine no
beer for just 30 days
definitely benefits a lot of people so
we spoke with crystal riccio from
roseman university she says bars can
offer mocktails during dry january to
support those who are participating she
says
taking a pause for some period of time
during the year can have many benefits
she also says that if you're drinking
more than seven drinks in a week for a
woman 14 for a man that could be viewed
as excessive
if it's repeated behavior over a period
of time this could be a sign of a larger
problem and it's time to seek
help any time that you're approaching
someone that you have concern that might
have a substance use disorder
approaching it from a place of love is
absolutely necessary
having that compassion to know that they
may not identify the problem themselves
and just being humble about it and
approaching them in a real way
from a place of love
so here's some tips to finish out your
dry january or even just start today
give yourself maybe a week of no alcohol
so here are some tips listed here find a
substitute for non-alcoholic drinks
maybe sparkling water or the virgin
version of your favorite cocktail avoid
temptation
stay in the house for a week maybe not
going out to eat or happy hours create a
support system have an accountability
partner do it together with somebody and
don't give up if you slip up don't feel
guilty begin the next day and of course
you don't just have to do a dry month at
the beginning of the year hey you can
take february maybe you just carve out a
day for valentine's day because you may
have a glass of wine or champagne there
but you can do dry a month anytime
taking a pause from alcohol bianca
holmen live local now